AND QUINN HUGHES ABOUT 53 POINTS
TOUCH, NOW WATCHED BY MICHAEL
KNIGHTS KEEPING IT IN, DADONOV
FEEDS THE BLUE LINE AND THEODORE
THAN 40 TO GO IN THE VEGAS
GOLDEN KNIGHTS POWER PLAY AND
THIS PASS, BROKEN WAS LOOKING FR
MAKE THE PLAYOFFS IN EACH OF
THEIR FIRST FIVE YEARS AND
AND KOLESAR WHEELS B
DOORSTEP BY JANMARK BUT DEMKO
MAKING TWO THE DRAW AS
THATCHER DEMKO WHO HAS
BEEN BUSY, EARLY.T MUCH.
NOT MUCH.
THAT IS A GOOD SHOT.
ABOUT A MONTH AGO TO STAY IN
VEGAS, HORVAT HERE, LEFW
THE GOAL DEEP, INTO
THE VEGAS ZONE AND: DERMOTT, HIY
THERE, AT CENTRE, CREATING THIS.
NET AND OUT THE NEAR SIDE A
ATn S.: THE FIRST HALF OF
THAT DOUBLE MINOR TO BACK POINTE
BY SPEC TO PODKOLZIN, A
HE WAS FAVOURING COUPLE OF PERIS
AND EKMAN-LARSSON THERE.
THAT ONE MIGHT HAVE HIT McNABB
IN F.
>> John G.: THIS IS A TIMELY
GOAL AND MILLER,
THEN ABLE TO MAKE THAT SAVE AND
IS HORVAT.
DISHING I I NOW, TURNS.
THAT ONE INTO ON
DERMOTT, TEEING IT UP HERE FORH.
>> John G.: OH, BOY, CANUCKS
HERE GETTING CHANCES NOW AND
THTH HURRY.
TEN SECONDS LEFT.
AND
DOWN, GETTING UP, MARCHESSAULTHO
NOW PULLING AWAY AND THREE VEGAS
GOLDEN